after weeks of top democrats all the way  up to the president calling republicans  fascists comparing us to al qaeda  encouraging people to kill maga voters a  new death threat from the libs has just  dropped this one care of democrat  senator maisie hirono when i hear my  colleagues talking about how  you know it should be states rights or  government should not be telling us what  to do  the word hypocrites  it doesn't even go  far enough  to call them out on what they're doing  this is an outright attack on women in  this country that is how i see it i use  the floor but clearly you know this is  a  literally  called to arms lest there be any  confusion maisie hirono is calling on  her fellow democrats to pick up guns and  shoot us